[Music]
well what Star Wars does is it tells us
about parents and children and how
connected each is to the other and it is
probably the most stirring tale I think
of boys need for dad and a dad's need
for a boy that we have in modern culture
and it kind of nails some of the
intensity of those feelings it also and
I think this is equally deep tells us
something about Redemption so the idea
is that if you can get your kid to love
you it's probably going to be okay and
also if you do something heroic and good
you can probably be redeemed in some
sense of your soul whether we're talking
about religion or not you can be
redeemed even if you were really a creep
before that at least if what you do that
redeems yourself is very major and
important as it certainly was in Star
Wars I think we're gonna see themes
about parents and kids and redemption in
the in the new episodes as well in terms
of Empires and Republic's what the
movies kind of capture and I think nail
is that authoritarianism has a bit of an
appeal the idea that you know an
authoritarian leader can get something
done and maybe take a little bit of the
chaos that freedom creates and get it
into some sort of management management
and that can make life a little more
orderly and people like that but it also
tells us that in every human heart there
is a kind of need for freedom meaning
there isn't going to be a boot on your
face and there's going to be a capacity
for governing yourself and the tale of
the appeal of authoritarianism which
really kind of captures what happens in
Nazi Germany and captures a little bit
some of the appeal of authoritarians all
over the world including currently
Turkey it gets that and it gets that in
a way that is true to the arc of human
history and the failures of
authoritarianism because of
people don't like a food in their face
it kind of lightly but but memorably
captures that as well so if you're in
you know a country that's poor and where
people's property rights aren't secure
or you go on the streets and someone
might beat you up or if you're in a
country that's doing pretty well like
the United States and some European
nations but terrorism is a risk or if
terrorism is unlikely still you might
get something stolen or somebody might
knock you out because there's violent
crime or even if it doesn't happen to
you if you read it about the newspaper
then you might think law and order is a
pretty good corrective and even if law
and order means that civil liberties and
civil rights will be reduced maybe
that's a trade you'll be willing to take
and we certainly saw that in the United
States at times over the past let's say
40 years and while in the United States
in my view
nothing really horrific has happened in
terms of the rise of authoritarianism
the fact that there have been movements
away from civil rights of liberties is
suggestive of something that's possible
when people feel really at risk so what
Star Wars captures and this makes that
transcend the kind of simple dichotomy
between the light side and the dark side
of the force is it says that you know
the dark side it does have a seductive
power either because it means that each
of us can wield power if we go dark or
because it means that somebody at least
is going to be controlled in control of
human impulses that can threaten us and
if the controlling power is reflecting
those forces that's not so good but some
people would rather live in an orderly
society that is not day to day let's say
unraveling than a society that is free
because freedom suggests the possibility
at least of
a little unraveling
[Music]
you